des guirlandes de bouchons en plastique
disposées un peu partout dans le collège
sentiment de jouars-pontchartrain à
l'occasion de la journée mondiale du
recyclage les enseignants ont organisé
une grande collecte et pour motiver les
enfants chaque niveau se retrouvent en
compétition en fait il ya eu des
bouchons par niveau parce que le
principe c'est de récupérer le maximum
de bouchons donc on a fait un petit
concours par niveau depuis le début de
la journée les élèves devaient venir
avec leur bouchon
voilà à quoi ils ont collecté un maximum
de bouchons pendant plusieurs semaines
et devait venir les déposer dans les
sacs on a à l'entrée du collège pour
pouvoir voilà avoir un maximum de
bouchons pour leur niveau pour l'instant
on est en train de gagner parce que on a
déjà deux sachets remplis par rapport
aux autres qu il y en a qui ont juste un
tout petit peu de bouchon dans leur
sachet oui on est bien parti oui et pour
avoir le plus de bouchons possible des
stands sont placées un peu partout dans
l'établissement comme cette animation
bowling ou pour deux strike l'élève
remporte un sachet de bouchons
finalement c'est un geste simple de
récupérer un bouchon au quotidien et et
ensuite de pouvoir servir une cause
comme celle du handicap qui nous a paru
importante et je trouve que allier les
deux environnement et solidarité c'est
quelque chose qui qui nous a bien plu
l'intégralité des bouchons sera remis au
profit de l'association handicap
prévention basée à chatou ils
permettront de financer du matériel pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
et n'offre aux lumas de beauté de porc
que deux fauteuils pour une quotidienne
comme une vingtaine de toilette
pour
offrir un show que c'est très important
de collecter des bouchons parce que ça
aide vraiment les gens à
à avoir du matériel qui leur sera utile
à l'avenir ou maintenant grâce à cette
journée de mobilisation le collège a
récolté 56 kg de bouchons